- [Narrator] On China's
southeastern coastline
facing Taiwan is the
Huian military airbase.
Since 2020, the airbase has
been significantly upgraded
with new hardened shelters,
an extended runway,
and a new apron for jet fighters.
Huian is just one of at least
a dozen Chinese airbases
in southern China
that have seen infrastructure
upgrades in recent years.
Defense analysts say these changes
are part of China's preparations
for conflicts over Taiwan.
The self-governing island
that Beijing claims
and has pledged to take
by force if necessary.
Here's how China has been
upgrading its airbase
to strengthen its military capabilities
and what challenges that poses
for Taiwan and its allies
in the events of a conflict.
The Wall Street Journal
asked security analysts
to study satellite imagery
of over a dozen air bases
within 500 miles of Taiwan.
Alex Neill is a former defense analyst
for the British government
and specializes in Asia Pacific security.
- The modernization and the upgrades
of these air bases has
been specifically focused
on the ability to move air
assets to these airfield,
which are close to the
theater of of battle.
- [Narrator] In its
biannual defense report,
Taiwan warned China's recent construction
at airfields along the coastline
is designed to seize air superiority
in the events of war
across the Taiwan Strait.
(officer speaking in a foreign language).
- [Narrator] China's air
force has been expanding
its spaces to accommodate a
wide range of military aircraft
ready for different types of combats.
These upgrades can be seen
in the Longtian airfield,
one of China's closest base to Taiwan.
- Longtian airfield is
quite a special example of
the PLA'S modernization
because it not only has
an array of helicopters
and fighter jets,
at one end of the airfield,
you can make out camouflaged
hardened shelters,
which are housing UAVs.
So large drones,
which can be in the air
reconnoitering the battle space.
- [Narrator] China has
developed supersonic drones
such as the WZ-8,
capable of penetrating deep
behind enemy radar systems.
A leaked paper from the Pentagon suggests
that WZ-8 drone is based
here at the Lu'an airbase,
and satellite imagery
shows significant upgrades
have taken place in recent years.
The leaked paper suggests
the upgraded basis
on China's southern coast would operate
as potential landing fields for the drone
during reconnaissance
missions over Taiwan.
China has been working on
the so-called survivability
of its air assets in the
face of a retaliatory strike
by hardening the bunkers
where aircraft are stored
with layers of reinforced
concrete and steel.
- If we look at a closeup
of this airfield here,
you can see hardened
shelters in this area,
so aircraft on the apron would be able to
advance quite quickly into
these hardened shelters
to refuel them to arm them.
- [Narrator] The purpose
of hardening shelters
is to ensure aircraft can
survive direct strikes
on an airbase,
allowing jet fighters to keep flying
once a conflict has started.
- If there were an immediate
threat to the airfield itself
through missiles launched at sea
or indeed Taiwanese or U.S. aircraft,
it would be to able to
withstand a preemptive strike
or to have a second strike capability.
- [Narrator] A number of
the airbases like Anqing
also have runways with direct
access to mountain bunkers.
- Under this mountain,
there will be munition storage facilities
as well as fuel and
potentially accommodation
for military personnel sheltering during
an attack on the airfield.
- [Narrator] The satellite images
show workers been undertaken
to harden the entrances
to these bunkers,
replacing exposed entrances
with what appear to be
reinforced structures topped
with a camouflage layer.
Analysts say these changes are
part of China's preparations
to maintain its air force
in the event of a conflict.
The chinese military is also enhancing
the survivability of its air bases
by constructing new air defense units.
- If you look at this,
you can see this cog type configuration,
which has a perimeter fence
its own accommodation,
hardened sheds for the missile batteries
and radar capabilities,
which would rapidly deploy onto this cog
to provide air defense.
(military officers speaking
in a foreign language)
- [Narrator] Surface
to air defense systems
are designed to protect ground
positions from air attacks.
These systems are capable
of protecting airfields
from multiple threats,
including high altitude bombers.
- So these air defense facilities
are not just for the airfield,
but they're more broadly speaking
a joined up chain of air defense.
- [Narrator] China's Ministry of Defense
didn't respond to a request
for comments on the recent
upgrades of its air bases.
U.S. officials say China's military
is rapidly catching up
to Western air forces.
- [Neill] It's clear that
there's been a saturation
of this whole area with airbases.
The united states and its allies
are also needing to use
their own geographical reach
in order to counter this saturation.
- [Narrator] If China
were to invade Taiwan,
Beijing knows it could spark a
wider conflict in the region.
- There's no doubt as demonstrated by the
hardening of these bases,
that the PLA military
leadership is aware that
they will be big targets
for the United States
and Taiwanese forces
if there were to be
across straight invasion.
(dramatic music)